at what age is there an age that it's
like look 21 i still live with my
parents cool they're still like 21. all
right 25 maybe but like 30
35 like at what point because we're
talking about millennials still living
at home with their parents i would say
what age is like dude i don't care what
your ambition is what's the number i i
would say a year post college oh just
one you're giving dude one year
a year post college okay so i feel like
you graduate i feel like you graduate uh
college okay what twenty two twenty
three sure eight no you're like yeah
you're 24. yeah right 23 22. yeah
you get a year on your own right figure
out some people go to college they move
back home they're trying to figure out a
job it gives them gives them a year to
get theirself situated okay and then
that following year like you need to
have a plan okay rather now like i said
unless you're living with your parents
to save up to
for a bigger purpose then yeah but you
need to figure out a means of income
okay so jenny's given to homeboys one
year you got one year from the day you
graduate college to get your [ __ ]
together and then she's breaking up with
you john jenny said i don't care about
covet bro get your [ __ ] together
the voice of god david thank you nancy
what is an appropriate age for a dude to
still you know to move out of their
parents house to get out of there 21 she
she gave him basically until 23 24. like
you got one year after 24 25. okay so so
jenny's even given another year she's 25
what about you
i mean 24 25 just i feel like that's
around the time people at least try to
do something different because
especially if you're dating somebody and
they are trying to figure things out
there has to be like milestones they're
hitting like they have to be actively
looking they have to be actively trying
something otherwise they're just like a
basement baby that's nancy gotcha
so basically 23 24 even 25.
if they're still living with their
parents okay 30 caught that stuff no no
okay
there's a lesson out there
you're doing some latino stuff where i
gotta get you yeah my bad
when she gets mad
anyway here's my two thoughts uh my two
cents on on basically what's going on
high school after college cool
here's here's here's my so you know i
literally my parents like kicked me out
of the house like 17 like get like get a
life you're out of here boom i haven't
lived with my parents since like
although i did crash at my mom's house
this week just
just you know to spend some time with my
mom but in general i've been supporting
my since i was 18. okay
but
if you are living at home and you're a
freaking grown-up let's say 22 plus
you
should still
have to contribute what does that mean
i'm not talking i'll take the garbage
out mom you're either paying the
utilities
you pay with rent you afford your own
car payment and it's not because the 400
is that big of a deal but you need to
set boundaries and you need to learn
lessons because let me tell you
something life only gets more expensive
year after year after year after year so
if you're still 30 and relying on your
pair like i met some dude he was working
at publix the other day and he saw me
wearing the valuetainment i am an
entrepreneur shirt and he came up to me
and he's like hey man you know i really
just i like your shirt what's tell me
about entrepreneurship i don't know i'm
like how old you you're 30. and you work
at publix he's like yeah but you know
i'm like where do you live with your
parents and he's like i don't know i
kind of want to be an entrepreneur i was
like buddy you got a lot of things to
figure out here homie
okay
and the point is this is that
i'm sure that person
his parents are not charging him any
rent and it's just very comfortable for
him to just live year after year after
year paying rent i doubt he's bringing
any chicks back to his parents place
next thing you know he's freaking 30
working at publix wondering why he can't
get his [ __ ] together there's something
called tough love and i don't have kids
or anything like that but you better
believe if i had a 25 year old still
living at the house with me buddy you
either got to pay rent you got to like
there's going to be some boundaries
right there definitely am i right am i
wrong no you're very right and there's
something i do want to explain if you're
home living with your parents at that
age
don't think you have to rent or buy
something super lavishing to move out
like we live in a generation now where
everybody's like if i don't have the
most modern thing if my house isn't
trending i don't want it like you can
move out and live
it doesn't have to be so luxurious get a
roommate get two roommates exactly i
lived when i was exactly 25 26
with four roommates we had a ridiculous
house it was like a real world type
house we all threw in i think 500 bucks
you know this is at the time
but we're all just figuring it out
together a bunch of dudes and now
they're all married whatever but you got
to start somewhere because if you
eventually got to grow up if you just
stay with your parents and you're just
still continuing to do it it's not a
good look so at some point you got to
grow up nancy before we move on do you
have anything to add to this topic any
zingers any losers out there you want to
call out they're still living with their
parents now's your time no
[Laughter]
i would love if you were like no i would
love if you were like hey uh bill mcgee
in dallas texas you piece of [ __ ] that i
paid your i would love if you called
somebody out right now
uh
maybe next time
nancy you take another shot